How Art Can Transform the Internet
---- Subtitled by @londreterreando ----
In Thomas Pynchon's sprawling epic
post-modern novel Gravity's Rainbow,
there's a sequence in which the main
character is interrogated by the US government
under the influence of sodium amytal,
commonly called "truth serum".
The writing slips into
several dream-like rips on language.
In one telegram from Wisconsin,
launches the main character
into an obsessive meditation
on the possible constructions
of a six-word sequence:
"You never did. The Kenosha kid".
As more and more examples are presented,
each with different punctuations,
we become aware of
a key post-modern truth
that words can point toward reality,
that they can never get there;
they always mean different things
in different contexts.
But just how many different
contexts are there?
Well, Pynchon only gives us seven.
There are far too many
punctuation marks and emphases,
far too many combinations
for a single writer to catalog them all.
Besides, in the aesthetic universe
of the novel,
cataloging them all would be
exhaustive and redundant.
Enter the Internet and
a man named Darius Kazemi.
"Hi, everybody.”
He makes what he likes to call
"weird internet stuff".
"I make what I like to call
'weird internet stuff',
you have watched it recently
come to accept is internet art."
Last year Darius made a Twitter bot
that did what the writer
Thomas Pynchon can't ever do.
It automatically generates
a different construction
of the "You never did. The Kenosha Kid"
sequence every two hours.
As of this video, the account
has already tweeted 8600 times,
and with the number
of permutations possible
it could continue for years
without exhausting everyone.
Go there sometime.
Try reading a few out loud.
The effect of Pynchon's
language experiment
is compounded, updated.
The truth it wants to communicate
is received in a new way,
and the exhaustiveness that would have been
inappropriate in a book
is made novel and strangely vital
in this new form.
I think what this shows us is
that the aesthetics of Internet art,
art made with and for
and on the Internet,
won't conform to any that we've
known before.
And that's fitting because
a lot of internet art is made
unlike any art that came before.
Because Amy's twitter bots are made
with paintbrushes or musical instruments.
They're made it
with algorithms with code.
This is what the Kenosha Kid
Twitter bot really looks like.
Is there any beauty in that?
What about this bot?
No, it's just a set of instructions
Here's what those instructions do.
This program and these rules
perform a simple task:
they access the Texas
Department of Criminal Justice
and pour from the public last word
statements of death row inmates
any sentence that contains
the word "love".
This art pieces are out to make
an overtly political statement
on capital punishment
like all good art.
This project organizes elements
in the world around it
helping audience see
and feel in a new way.
The difference is that
the world Kazemi's commented on
isn't the physical world, not really.
It's the digital world,
the world of the Internet,
and indeed much of our digital
Internet art is focused on itself
on the visible and,
more importantly,
invisible aspects of the network
that's all around us.
"Computation is now everywhere;
it is layered over everything
and we are living inside
that computer as well."
That's James Bridle,
a critic in digital artist.
Bridle did a project
recently called Rainbow Planes,
a project that started when he noticed
some odd artifacts from Google Earth
of planes with rainbow-after images.
"It's a glitch, but like all
true glitches,
it's not just a mistake,
it's a kind of an opportunity
to look through
into the underlying systems
that produce this image."
In this case it shows us that
the satellites composing these images
aren't using cameras but rather
are collecting data from a broad swath
of the electromagnetic spectrum.
"And they record red,
green and blue separately
when they make these data images.
And so occasionally you find
within satellite images these artifacts
which produced by fast moving objects."
Bridals's digital art wants to help us see
the way technology sees us:
how hugely powerful systems
have moved slowly
into our lives without much protest.
These systems are not like us:
we see with eyes, they see with data;
we think with minds,
they think with algorithms.
Art like this shows us that our increasing
dependence on sophisticated technologies
comes at the cost of substituting
our values and our motives for theirs.
So maybe the aesthetic value
of Internet art
is measured by its ability
to help us see the Internet,
just as a novel can help us see language
or an image can help us see reality.
That's just an idea and I can't say
how valid it is for you,
but I think we do have to try to develop
an aesthetic for this new digital art,
away by which we can determine
which of it is good, which of it is crap,
and which we consider truly essential.
Because what we think is great art
speaks ultimately to what
we think is valuable in culture.
And articulating our values about
the Internet, the global network,
in the years before
it consumes everything
might just be the most important thing
our generation could ever do.
Hey, everybody! Thanks for watching.
I'm getting the scene
just before sunset here.
Welcome to 2016!
If you want to help me out in 2016
you can pledge $1 or $3 per video
by clicking right below here
and going to my Patreon page.
That money will go toward making
50 new videos for you, guys, this year.
It is an exciting prospect
to make what I hope is content unique
to YouTube and the Internet.
So thank you guys again.
I will see you all next Wednesday.